as the Sun fades away over an island in  the Okavango Delta the evening chorus of  bell frogs begins in the background the  camp prepares for dock  at nights you need to be very careful  near the water  listen be aware when you fetch water for  your evening wash there's all only the  Predators on land that have become more  active no eyes closed  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  coming together for dinner each night is  a ritual music and laughter serious  conversations and tears an expedition  family  the campfire you can watch it for hours  while listening to the wilderness  thoughts and ideas float into an art of  your mind at peace you feel alive  [Music]  these are the first sounds of the  approaching door  what a wonderful place to wake up after  a night like that nothing compares to  being connected to real life in the  world  you